des arbres et de loups
de l'eau et des arbres à perte de vue
voilà l'image sauvages que l'on peut
admirer en arrivant ici
c'est celle du poumon vert de la planète
et pourtant c'est un tout autre paysage
qui très vite s'étale sous nos yeux qui
n'a plus rien à voir avec la forêt
vierge
une nature entièrement remodelée par
l'homme
le royaume de l'agriculture intensive
des parcelles immense à perte de vue
le mato grosso et grand comme deux fois
la france
sa superficie est presque entièrement
dédié
au soja
[Musique]
au moment des récoltes une armada de
machines géantes s'affairent dans un
ballet incessant
aussitôt les moissonneuses batteuses
passé suivent à quelques mètres derrière
des enjeux qui sème déjà pour la récolte
suivante
car à peine quelques mois plus tard le
soja sera de nouveau fin prêt à être
moissonnée
au brésil cette plante se récolte trois
fois par an au lieu d'une seule fois
chez nous pour fournir la terre en soja
le saut chaque fait poser une énorme
pression sur la réserve en eau du brésil
et voici pourquoi
tout d'abord cette plante a
naturellement besoin de beaucoup d'eau
pour pousser
[Musique]
mais il ya un autre problème qui prouve
l'impact du soja sur cette ressource la
culture de cette plante est en train de
dérégler le climat de toute la région
je pense qu'il va pleuvoir la
whey à la croix que cela traduit bien la
terre ouais c'est très sec la
au mato grosso depuis quelques saisons
un phénomène nouveau est apparu ils
pointent dans les champs le manque d'eau
rend les sols très secs contre coût
direct pour guilherme et son soja pousse
plus lentement
généralement il ya davantage de pluie à
cette période cette année c'est plus sec
que la normale est
le climat de ces deux dernières années
de plus en plus difficiles à prévoir
c'est beaucoup moins stable que dans le
passé
pour pouvoir garder son rythme de trois
récoltes par an guilherme est content
même puiser de l'eau dans le sol pour
irriguer ses champs un comble dans cette
région tropicale aux pluies jusqu'à
présent abondante
d'autant que pour les scientifiques
c'est l'arrivée de la culture du soja
qui est précisément la cause de ce
dérèglement climatique
car le mato grosso n'a pas toujours eu
ce visage il y a encore une vingtaine
d'années cet état brésilien n'était que
ça vanne boisé forêts un poumon vert qui
fournit de l'oxygène en grande quantité
à notre planète mais aussi ce que l'on
sait moins énormément d'eau
quand il pleut l'eau est absorbée par
les arbres puis avec la chaleur une
partie de l'eau s'évapore dans le ciel
elle forme des nouveaux nuages qui
produiront une nouvelle pluie
sauf qu'un événement majeur va
bouleverser ce site
dans les années 80 le gouvernement
décide de sacrifier tout un écosystème
la forêt est rasé puis brûlé pour en
faire des terres de culture intensive
économiquement beaucoup plus rentables
[Musique]
sur cette photo satellite prise en 1996
par la nasa l'état du mato grosso
envers des millions d'hectares de forêts
dix ans plus tard la transformation est
spectaculaire les champs ou totalement
remplacer les arbres
une déforestation industrialisés
orchestrée par le gouvernement mais dont
la planète paye déjà les conséquences
désormais au mato grosso le cycle de la
pluie est considérablement altéré
les arbres ont été remplacés par les
champs de soja
il pleut toujours
mais avec la chaleur le soja va rejeter
dans l'air moins d'eau que la forêt
des études la firme un champs de soja
génère presque deux fois moins de pluie
qu'une forêt
met à battre des forêts pour les
remplacer par du soja cela ne casse pas
seulement le cycle de la pluie cela des
vastes aussi une partie du bassin
amazonien qui contient 15 % de l'eau
vive mondial car peu à peu ses rivières
sans sable
c'est le cas de la rague ouailles à
l'une des plus importants de rivière du
brésil
max bayer en a fait son terrain d'étude
ce professeur de géologie analyse
l'impact de ces cultures intensives sur
les réserves d'eau douce l'art pour
l'art et on rentre par l'autre côté le
long de la rade ouailles à max bayer
nous fait découvrir ce paysage
inimaginable dans cette zone tropicale
un des bras de cette rivière a été
entièrement comblé par des dunes de
sable un désert née en quelques années
suite à la déforestation et à l'arrivée
du soja
a ptet sur nos cartes de navigation dans
les années 80 80 c'était encore indiqué
qu'il y avait ici un bras de rivière qui
coule et autour de cette petite île
à partir des maisons une trentaine
d'années à peine attaquer là comme un
sac cette rivière a disparu en se
remplissant de ça la veille
sur des kilomètres
ici le sable à remplacer l'eau
pour max nous assistons à un désastre
écologique avec pour seuls responsables
le soja
pour nous montrer comment cette culture
peut avoir causé de tels dégâts max nous
entraîne un peu au bord de l'ancienne
rivière
ici à quelques mètres de la rive tous et
encore il ya peu de la forêt mais tout a
été arraché et or tous des boisés cela
perturbe le cycle de l'eau dans le sol
car le soja comme ces herbes à de
petites racines des racines incapable de
faire le même travail que celles des
arbres tech ici vous voyez ces arbres de
la forêt et leurs racines vont jusqu'à
15 20 m de profondeur
elles peuvent pomper l'eau très profond
en cas de sécheresse et elles retiennent
mieux l'eau en réserve comme des éponges
masse et
coisy on arrache ses arbres et leurs
racines et qu'on les remplace par du
soja compères tout ça avec ses petites
racines cette plante ne pas puiser l'eau
bien profond et surtout quand la pluie
tombe l'eau ne va plus infiltrées
lentement dans la terre elle va
s'écouler en surface
elle va raviné ça va creuser le sol et
ça ça provoque des glissements de
terrain
et voilà comment en supprimant les
racines des arbres on a rendu ses terres
plus friables à chaque pluie une partie
du sol et emporter il va peu à peu en
sable et la rivière et lara gouaille à
n'est pas la seule touchée
l'ensemble des fleuves brésilien qui
prennent leur source au milieu des
champs de soja est concerné
des fleuves cruciaux pour notre planète
car il alimente le bassin amazonien la
plus grande réserve d'eau douce vivent
au monde
non